-My next guest is known as
the queen of Latin pop,
and she has a brand-new album
out this Friday called
"Desamorfosis."
Please welcome Thalia!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness!
Look at this! Come on!
-Jimmy, mi amor!
-I'm so happy that you're here,
number one.
Number two, thank you
for premiering your video
tonight for "Mojito."
It's a big deal,
and we love that.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God, I'm so excited
about this.
Thank you for having me here.
-How is the family? How is
Tommy doing, your husband?
-Tommy, you know, he's always
busy, always working.
He has like three projects
right now.
You probably know all about it
because you guys talk
all the time.
-Tommy Mottola is your husband.
-Exciting.
-How did you and Tommy meet?
Do you remember?
-Oh, my --
Okay, this was a blind date,
and it was
Gloria and Emilio Estefan
that kept telling us,
"You know what?"
Emilio kept saying, "Thalia,
you have to meet this guy.
You have to meet this guy.
He's like you.
He thinks like you."
And I kept asking him,
"Okay, but tell me --
tell me about this guy,
what he does."
"He just got divorced.
He has two kids."
And I'm like, "No thank you."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm free right now.
I feel very good right now."
And he kept telling Tommy
the same like,
"You have to meet this girl.
I mean, you guys are like --
like so alike."
And then Tommy's like, "Okay,
but tell me what she does.
Tell me about her."
-[ Laughs ] My God,
that's a good impression.
-And then he's like,
"Okay, she's an actress,
and she's a singer,"
and Tommy was like,
"Nope, thank you very much."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh. That's hilarious.
-"That's it."
One year and a half,
after we met at Scalinatella --
you probably love that story,
because you like to eat like me.
-I love Scalinatella.
-And from that day till now,
20-plus years,
two kids, gorgeous kids.
-Come on. Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I've seen photos of your
wedding, 'cause it was --
I mean, everyone who was anyone
was at your wedding.
I mean, it was insane.
-It was really something.
It was insane.
It was, you know, the Mexicans
and the Italians,
and then New York scene,
and then it was,
like, mariachi band,
and then it was a big band.
And then at the end of
the night -- I don't know how --
up on stage,
it was Donna Summer,
Gloria Estefan, Marc Anthony.
Danny DeVito was, like, dancing.
[ Laughter ]
-I love how Danny DeVito got
the biggest round of applause.
-Hold on. Pero hold on.
He was dancing,
holding on Jennifer Lopez waist.
He's not stupid.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He is not stupid.
He was doing the conga
with Jennifer.
[ Laughter ]
Jennifer was so happy,
and he was like, "Yeah!"
[ Laughter ]
A lot of tequila.
A lot of tequila that night.
-Yeah. Good, good, good.
[ Applause ]
I want to talk about
"Desamorfosis,"
but first, I wanted to mention
that, at one point,
some of your songs were banned
at one point,
when you first came out.
-Yes. Yes.
-Because they were too racy
or what was it?
-They were, like, very,
you know, a lot of, like,
sexual content and a lot
of very explicit things,
and about concepts that back
then probably were, like,
too much for, like,
a 17-year-old girl.
And they banned me on radio.
And 30 years after, right now,
we just released
the same albums,
my first three solo albums,
digitally,
and they were like number one,
two, three -- They're top five.
-Yeah. The top --
-In the digital era.
-That's what I'm talking about.
They come out now.
That's got to feel good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
See?
-I'm like, "Yes!"
-Well, you have a new album.
It comes out this Friday,
"Desamorfosis."
What can people expect
from this album?
-First of all,
that sounds so good.
"Desamorfosis."
That sounds great.
-I did okay? "Desamorfosis."
-Yeah. "Desamorfosis."
"Desamorfosis."
-"Desamorfosis."
-Yes!
-Thank you. You have to help me,
Thalia, please.
-You did good. So, "desamor"
means "heartbreak."
Okay?
"Amor" is "love," of course.
"Morphosis" is "morfosis."
It's like a play on three words.
And that's what love is.
Love is an adventure.
And it has all this complexity
of what love is.
And it's a very honest album.
I talk about all my things
there from beginning to end.
And it's the first time
that I did this.
It's like going to therapy,
and it was amazing.
[ Laughter ]
-I love there's a song on here
called "Tick Tock,"
because you have
a giant following on TikTok.
And it's funny
because some generations
watch you on TikTok, and they
know you only from TikTok.
-Yeah, they think I'm a TikToker
or, like, I'm a YouTuber
or, like, I'm an influencer.
And then they discover,
when they Google me,
"Oh, my gosh, she's sings?"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God. I mean, come on.
Exactly, like, "What?"
-It's really cool.
And my fans, Jimmy, my fans
from all over,
they send me -- they tag me
and they DM me all the time
like, "You know what? There's
a new singer here in Brazil.
You have to know all about her.
You and her would be amazing."
Or my fans from Greece --
"This is the new video director.
Look at what he's doing.
You have to work."
So they're always tagging me,
and that's how I find
my collabs lately.
You know, I just DM them.
"Hey, I love your music."
And they're like,
"A-Are you the Thalia? Are you?"
-They're like, "Really? Is this
really coming from Thalia?"
Yeah. Look at you. I love it.
And then, I want to talk about
"Mojito," because I think
this is a perfect summer jam,
not only is it
the perfect summer beverage.
[ Laughter ]
Why is it called "Mojito"?
-Well, it is like a very --
First of all,
the song is super sexy.
It has real music that,
to me, was important.
You know, it has, like,
the guitar and the bongos,
and the lyrics are like
what you said.
It's like the perfect
summer song.
It's refreshing.
It's like mint, sugar, bubbles.
-Yes!
-Kisses, lips, and oh!
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are unbelievable. Thalia!
Her new album "Desamorfosis"
is out this Friday.